look at the media coverage they wanted
to paint everyone there as either part
of a militia or at the very least
creating civil unrest so isn't this a
brilliant ploy the Second Amendment
should apply to everyone except for
those who may want to cause civil unrest
or intimidate people really what
qualifies a civil unrest or intimidating
people everyone at this rally or anybody
with a Facebook post that says governor
Ralph Northam go home or a kick Northam
out we're hearing kill kill we're
hearing they should forgo their second
Amendment rights question of the day
have you or had you been following
rather the media's coverage of the
Virginia protests the firearm protests
and based on the media's coverage in the
media's maybe perception what was your
impression of the rally now I don't want
you to cheat comment right now pause
before you watch this entire segment
because obviously this segment will act
as a cheat sheet it was my little it's
not but we were sold so yesterday for
those who don't know there was the the
rally in in Richmond Virginia
this is the all worrisome violent
massive pro-gun demonstration that we
were told for which time to hide our
kids
the governor of course Ralph Northam and
many in the media they've they've
consistently misrepresented this whole
is it by the way we were fooled we were
planning on going down to this rally
ourselves and instead opted to go to a
women's March rally in Texas which ended
up being far more violent because I've
assaulted by not one but two count them
two transgenders not the one gender
dysphoria two to gender dysphoria you
obsessive compulsive count alright so
here's what I want to do I want to kind
of shoot you straight set the record
straight between what the media was
claiming would or did go down versus
what actually happened okay so claiming
Berwyn everyone's been following us here
yes yeah was they were protesting the
people who were showing over protesting
bills that were simply about
common-sense gun control this is the
claim we see this a lot for context by
the way again
the person making this claim was
Virginia Governor Ralph Northam so yeah
take it with a grain of salt by the way
I still don't think we know whether he
is the one in the hood or the one in the
shoe polish you decide which is what
there is no safe out here it's a shot do
we know I don't think we know I have no
idea it doesn't really and something to
that you see what the media they really
try to minimize the laws again this term
common-sense gun control is throwing out
a lot I think everyone is on board with
common-sense gun control but people
wouldn't be on board with this bill if
they understood that common-sense gun
control already exists so let's see how
this bill was described by those in the
media and in turn painting the people
who were protesting it tensions have
been rising since Democrats regained
control of the state legislature and
proposed several gun control examples
including limiting upon purchases
background checks a red-flag measure
also a limiting a citizen's to one
handgun purchase a month also giving
greater authority to a local government
to ban guns or weapons in public spaces
for instance at protests so those are a
couple of the committee in Virginia
Beach this weekend we lost 12 precious
lives we have four individuals that are
currently fighting for their lives and
you know Virginians have spoken and said
it's time for us as legislators and as
their governor to act was that governor
that was governor Ralph Northam I didn't
recognize him without that thing if you
could leave the lights on because he
gets a little scared the media was
actually correct about that these bills
are the bill proposed legislation would
limit magazines that hold ten or more
rounds require some additional
background checks even though we have
background checks right turn all state
owned and leased buildings into gun-free
zones yeah limiting purchases to one
handgun a month and a big one strip
parents are the right to decide when
their child is responsible enough to
access a firearm and by the way a lot of
people who may sound horrified who
aren't firearm people kids can learn how
to shoot pretty young certainly younger
than 18 some of the best competitive
shooters in the country are in their
teens and a big thing will come back to
this they would also ban the public
assembly of armed individuals who have
the intent of intimidating others and
that really matters because specifically
you'll see it was conflated was the idea
intent to intimidate others with militia
language you heard a lot about militia
this could be training a militia
these could be militia people these
could be these two militia militia
militia militia whoosh part of your ass
is a well-regulated militia all of it
and that is significant and for people
who don't necessarily and we'll get to
some more claims in a second so you'll
say well why would you ever need more
than ten rounds you saw this in
California right with a bullet button
and it's I think now actually it's even
hard to purchase ammo in California
why would anyone need a 10-round
magazine and this is my biggest problem
with the firearm legislation that they
proposed
crow why is it my business there are
plenty of people and there are plenty of
reasons that someone could need more
than ten rounds in a firearm I've had
people ask me live on air in Russia
today why would you ever need more than
one firearm I don't know because I have
more than one room I have a flip switch
and things that rotate too it is a
mechanism but here let me give you a
specific reason it shouldn't matter why
someone needs more than ten rounds in a
magazine but practically speaking the
average number of rounds fired in an
encounter with a criminal is 3.6 about
3.6 now keep in mind that's the average
now let's think about that for a second
okay
let's say maybe you're not an average
shooter maybe not like Bill is a
competitive shooter who's very good
maybe you are like most women who
purchase a firearm go to the range every
now and then to stay sharp enough and
then either keep it next to your bed
keep it in your purse which is
ill-advised or keep it on your person
but you're not a great shot now let's
add two intruders yeah yeah you're out
of luck by the way criminals in case you
hadn't known they're committing violent
crimes they tend to travel in packs yeah
give you time to reload either exactly
I'm gonna pause and this is something
else a lot of people know there's a
reason that police officers switched to
semi automatics they realized that they
were being outgunned often on the street
before that the standard was revolvers
I'm a big revolver guy but it's not my
business to tell somebody how many
rounds they can have in a magazine
especially when the cutoff is arbitrary
and for all intents and purposes here
someone could very easily cross that
threshold into needing more than ten
rounds it's not like it's some
unreasonable number to think of this one
might need 15 runs the most popular
firearms in the country hold more than
ten rounds that's what they have to be
an adapted for all states like
California I think is pretty important
and to go back to the idea of civil
disorder and they talk about militias
well here's the thing people talk about
maybe some people who might want to
cause civil disorder or people who might
want to join militias and what they try
and do is inextricably time militias
with neo-nazis right
but hold on a second if we're talking
about civil disorder or militias that's
exactly why the Second Amendment was
written yeah I know you may not like
those terms but guess what it was for
people who may want to cause some kind
of civil disorder against a tyrannical
government and creating their own
militia I know people think the militia
was the military no that's why it says
militia , the right of the people to
keep and bear arms shall not be
infringed what are the framers of the
Constitution have to say about that
who's the militia well let's go to
George Mason June 16th 1788 I will quote
directly I asked who are the militia
then consists now of the whole people
except a few public officers because
they're jerks which actually does the
opposite you didn't think the government
officials carry firearms or there were a
few public officials who had made
towards nations interest is to keep and
bear arms except for car by the way
these are just the bills that I've been
proposed so far there are more in the
works of course including red flag laws
which nobody can clearly define
including people you had on the show and
this is okay another claim that they
made was that this was going to be of
course a neo-nazi rally oh boy a
gathering of white supremacists even
going so far as comparing it directly to
Charlottesville everywhere Richmond
Virginia is on high alert this morning
before a gun rights rally that local
authorities fear could turn violent the
FBI and local law enforcement say
they've received credible threats of
violence
organizers say tens of thousands of
people including white supremacist
groups and militias may gather in the
former Confederate capital today where
Democrats are proposing new gun laws no
one wants another incident like the one
we saw in Charlottesville in 2000 we is
the guy standing behind that man north
of
we're dreaming and violent why would the
Charlottesville when a neo-nazi rally in
2017 ended in the death of a counter
protester okay so that was the claim the
truth okay there were some white
supremacists there but not the
protesters in question as a matter of
fact listen to what this non governor
protester has to say I do not support in
any way shape or form govern Northlands
and the Democrats gun control you seen
on this this weekend they always brought
up the issue of race as though it's
nothing but white rednecks and
Hillbillies out here who care for the
Second Amendment what actually black
Americans the Asian Americans Hispanic
Americans Americans care about the
Second Amendment yeah gosh that's
embarrassing black people that hang it
up to these rallies that's weird
better get more shoe polish governor hit
the notification bell if you're
subscribed on YouTube and hit all
notifications because you won't be
notified of live streams and things like
that or on mobile now they've added
another step we do new videos they go up
every single night I think it's 8 p.m.
or 9 p.m. Eastern I don't know check for
yourself and of course join Mudd Club
that's the only way this content is
allowed to continue including changed my
mind where I'm violently assaulted like
gender dysphoria and stay tuned for that
all right here's another claim from
governor Ralph Northam that's him and
the media they tried to pay the trail
not only is racist and we were again
fooled by this we had plans we had
booked travel to go to this rally and
because the only information we had to
go on was sort of this circular loop of
the media and local law enforcement we
deemed it too risky for some of our crew
members because we couldn't get enough
security to protect all of them it's not
just myself anyway they tried to paint
this rally not just as racist but
overwhelmingly violent
we're seeing threats of violence we're
seeing threats of armed confrontation
and assault can't speak for yourself
governor north
we have received why is justin trudeau
in my law enforcement agencies that
there are real weird with malicious
plans for the rally that is planned for
Monday this includes
out-of-state militia groups and hate
groups planning to travel from across
the country to disrupt our democratic
process with acts of violence they're
not coming to peacefully protest they're
coming to intimidate and to cause harm
well the Capitol grounds they chanted
Northam out-group referencing Virginia's
Democratic governor ahead of today's
demonstration the governor declared a
state of emergency and banned all
weapons on Capitol ground but outside
that secured area many demonstrators
were heavily armed look at them they
look like soldiers they're some wearing
body armor and there are fears that
could be violence particularly from
white extremists do you know why they're
wearing body armor can you believe that
these clowns have body armor yeah they
look like soldiers stand by the way the
event truth truth it was entirely
peaceful okay see you then they even ran
a Chiron that seemed downright
disappointed look at this pro-gun rally
and peacefully despite fears of
extremist base of course we are all
thrilled that there was no violence um
and of course I typically wouldn't
suspect violence when I see people who
are carrying firearms because they tend
to be law-abiding citizens but I'm glad
that at least now governor Northam
concerns himself with violence in his
own state so in this particular example
if a mother is in labor I can tell you
exactly what would happen the infant
would be delivered the infant would be
kept comfortable the infant would be
resuscitated if that's what the mother
and the family desired and then a
discussion would ensue between the
physicians and the mother here's the
thing what's so uncommon ever even real
you know someone talks themselves into a
corner we've done that at some point
we're gonna oh you know what this may
sound bad
no it's not how I mean to say this let
me communicate in a different way and
you pivot it at no point so there no he
realized oh I'm advocating for the birth
of a baby and then the murder
let me sidestep using I feel good about
this I'm committed I'm gonna be going
down this path because I know at the end
of this primrose path is some shoe
polish and to a lipstick and by the way
the most telling part of the rally you
mentioned an tyfa anti-fur did show up
to this rally as we know they have been
historically a violent you're talking
about hundreds of arrests that's their
mission statement it's like Jerry
Maguire putting it in everyone's work
box that you know because it gets
inspired the middle of the night that's
how you and your balls out there and if
I showed up more subdued all of the
concrete and the punching and the
screaming and Nazis I just you throw in
a couple of guys who are obviously open
carrying and that concrete milkshake pit
stop at Mickey D's gets put on the back
burner that could be possibly could it
be fire okay and it's important by the
way if and if it had been violent which
they usually are what the media have
reported it remember the Ben Shapiro's
Utah event were an to the past out
weapons to yours truly and my producers
and two of them were arrested later on
that night according to the press it was
entirely peaceful they didn't even have
an interest in procuring the footage
that the police officers were combing
over from us they could not care any
less if we talk about the statistics
people always try and get into ok
statistics this person may have been
mentally disturbed versus fatherless
that's a big one fatherless person may
be in right wing baby Maiden left them
the one statistic that is completely
undeniable is that over 90% of mass
shootings occur in gun-free zones
if you are going to find one through
line it doesn't mean always okay I'm not
saying 100% of the time but there
certainly is a more consistent statistic
in them occurring in gun-free zones
than anything else that you can pick out
whether it's a shaved head whether it's
that he has blonde eyes whether it's
that he liked the Candice olam shows no
it is gun-free zones I think the number
used to be like 90 it's somewhere
between 92 and 97 percent of the time
depending what shapes you use and
something else that's really important I
know that this sounds may be a little
bit pedestrian because people make the
point so you know what stuffs a bad guy
with a gun a good guy with a gun and
then you have liberals going really a
good guy with a gun most the time it's
the police okay here's the thing how did
the police stop him every single bad guy
with a gun is stopped by a good guy with
a gun the good guy with a gun
maybe uniformed or maybe not yeah guess
what what do you think happens if the
cop is a truancy officer with a billy
club her it's 2:30 you're supposed to be
in home act and he's going to died it
it's because the cops show up with
firearms and this is what's so dangerous
to me a lot of people and I get it
people just [ __ ] about the mainstream
media or sometimes they say the
lamestream media okay but here's what
matters when you're talking about the
Second Amendment and this the Second
Amendment yeah grants the right of the
people the people make up the militia
the whole idea is this is a separate
mode we're not talking to the National
military we are talking about people
forming a militia when you look at these
bills they say hold on a second this is
only going to affect those who are
looking to cause civil unrest or those
who are looking to intimidate people at
public rallies that's a big piece that's
the piece that bothers me most about
this legislation well hold on a second
how is that determined yeah look at the
media coverage they wanted to paint as
half-asian lawyer bill pointed out
everyone there as either part of a
militia or at the very least creating
civil unrest so isn't this a brilliant
ploy the Second Amendment should apply
to everyone except for those who may
want to cause civil unrest or intimidate
people really what qualifies a civil
unrest turrent
hitting people everyone at this rally or
anybody with a Facebook post that says
governor Ralph Northam go home or a kick
Northam out we're hearing kill kill
we're hearing they should forgo their
second Amendment rights isn't that a
beautiful logic circular loop that then
short circuits enough that you
eventually end up playing blackface so
often you don't know whether you're the
governor of Virginia or Prime Minister
of Canada your guess is as good as mine
if you enjoyed this video you can
subscribe or hit the notification bell
and one of these buttons or watch
another video but you know this thing is
you don't um I mean you don't you don't
have to
I'm at I've I'd like it if you did you
know a lot of effort and do it whatever
you want